welcome to the program in a little bit
I'm going to talk to you about the
military mobilization that is happening
at significant cost to you as a taxpayer
related to the immigrant Caravan that is
very very slowly approaching the
us-mexico border but first we have
absolutely gigantic immigration news the
context of this is that Donald Trump has
been taking an increasingly hardline
stance really one of the more xenophobic
administration's in recent history when
it comes to immigration policy and
immigration policy ideas that we've
heard from Trump and from his cronies
and it was now revealed in an interview
with Axios on HBO that Donald Trump is
indeed in the process of ending
birthright citizenship by executive
order I guess I should better say
attempting to do that because there are
some serious legal questions as to
whether this is even constitutionally
possible and we're going to get to that
but the way that we learned that this
was going on is that Axios in advance of
their interview on HBO with Donald Trump
learned from sources within the
administration that Donald Trump was
plotting this he was getting legal
advice about whether it's possible to
end birthright citizenship without
making a change to the Constitution's
14th amendment and Trump seemed
surprised by the fact that his
interviewers knew this during the
interview but he did admit that he's
doing it and that there is a plan to do
it let's take a look at this clip from
Axios on HBO on immigration some legal
scholars believe you can get rid of
birthright citizenship without changing
the constitution with executive order
exactly right have you thought about
this tell me more it was always told to
me that you needed a constitutional
amendment guess what you don't you don't
number one number one you don't need
that number two an excellent is you
could a very much as well you can
definitely do it with an act of Congress
but now they're saying I can do it just
with an executive order now how
ridiculous were the only country in the
world where a person comes in has a baby
and the baby is essentially a citizen of
the United States for 85 years with all
of those benefits it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous and it has to end have
you talked about that with council yeah
so we're in the process in the process
it'll happen
we got executive order that's what
you're talking about yes exactly I
didn't think anybody but knew that but
me I thought I was the only one Jonathan
guess so Trump visibly surprised there
that Axios knew about it but he admits
it and I think this is such a massive
story that we we sort of have to segment
it to even talk about it at any
reasonable way so let's first talk about
the legal and then the kind of moral and
practical and political first the legal
argument Trump is making is that via
executive order you can effectively end
birthright citizenship without changing
the Constitution the Constitution has
amendments to it one of those amendments
the fourteenth is the source of
birthright citizenship as we have it
today so the the first question is can
Trump actually do this via the an
executive order rather than an act of
Congress or an amendment a change to the
Constitution it doesn't appear that he
can Trump is playing it extremely
confidently but if he tries this it's
going to be fought by the courts and
it's going to take a while oh the the
Fourteenth Amendment says all persons
born or naturalized in the United States
and subject to the jurisdiction thereof
are citizens of the United States and of
the State wherein they reside we aren't
going to solve that today but the
consensus seems to be among legal
scholars that Trump can't do this
although you do have sort of sporadic
conservative legal voices that say this
is something that that can be done the
legal consensus is Trump can't actually
do this if he tries the more pressing
question will be immediately this will
be fought in court would judges file an
immediate would they grant an immediate
emergency injunction when Trump signs
this order so that the law would remain
as it is until there is a definitive
answer which ultimately would probably
come from the supreme court once again
another reason why the supreme court
matters I would argue
that this is an authoritarian attempt by
Trump to overstep the spirit of the
Constitution even if he were legally
able to do it which again the legal
consents consensus right now is that
he's not able to do what about the moral
and the practical I'll tell you what is
not a good argument in favor of
birthright citizenship this is really
important
saying that it's been this way for a
long time and so it should stay this way
is not a good argument when you make the
argument from incumbency that this is
the way we've done it for a while you
end up in some logical quandary
that I think are problematic so we
should be able to defend the policy on
its merits not the fact that it's how
we've been doing it it also by the way
isn't quite so simple because we didn't
always have a 14th amendment the 14th
amendment also wasn't always applied in
the way that it is now to undocumented
immigrants so I don't think that the
precedent argument is a good argument
the argument I would make is that if you
get rid of birthright citizenship to
which country do you deport someone who
has been born and raised in the United
States exclusively do you send them to
the country their parents came from to
which they have no connection what if
the parents are dead
do you still deport them to some country
they've maybe never even been to that's
extraordinarily problematic and more
importantly we don't pun it or we
shouldn't punish kids for decisions that
their parents made period birthright
citizenship is also a protection against
racist politicians in the white house in
the house in the Senate who might want
to at some point enforce immigration law
in a way that is racially discriminatory
the Fourteenth Amendment and birthright
citizenship ensure that no matter which
group politicians want to target and
historically we've seen it done to black
people we've seen it done to Asians now
its Hispanics that seem to be on the
receiving end of this there is a
deliberate and arbitrary underclass that
can be created if you get rid of
birthright citizenship so it's really
important that we maintain it and lastly
it's also really important for you to
know that even with birthright
citizenship still the law of the land
which it is horrible things are being
done by this
raishin at the border the Trump
administration has already been denying
passport renewals to Latinos near the
border they have been trying to deport
minority US citizens without due process
Trump said it himself he would like to
do it so we are seeing the underpinnings
of building a de facto white ethno state
through immigration policy it's a
horrible reality and I believe that this
is also being talked about now as a
distraction from the flurry of
right-wing violence which is plaguing
the United States the cycle is something
starts impacting Trump's poll numbers
the way that his poll numbers have been
dipping since mid-september so all of a
sudden the focus is on something like
this we're going to talk about it in
significant detail but we also should
talk about the immigrant Caravan